hello everyone and welcome to another
game from round six of the 2019
Sinquefield cup a lot of you have
requested it so I first I thought I
wasn't gonna show it but then I decided
I will show it as well as the port above
the board says the most exciting one was
Caruana versus MVL with a crazy line of
the night off and if I do enjoy
something it's a crazy line of the night
off so I hope you enjoy it as well
without further ado let's check out the
game Caruana with the white piece is
opened with e4 we have c5 the Sicilian
defense with Knight to f3 d6 and of
course sorry about that we go into d4 if
you face maxim you play d4 you can
expect the night off with C captures
Knight captures in the knight to f6 with
Knight to c3 and maxeen goes for the
knight or defense and now the very
popular h3 everyone plays this nowadays
with E 5 kicking the knight back nice to
be 3 and Bishop to e6 with f4 by Fabi
already grabbing more space on the
kingside preparing g4 and f5 with g6
preparing to finca to the dark square
bishop and now Bishop to e2 to support
the cheap one and also maybe preparing
preparing to castle with Knight bt7 and
now g4 we've looped the c8 and now comes
f5 so threatening the bishop on e6 you
have to do something about it so Bishop
captures on b3 a capture some b3 and
this is where the party starts
as usual you always know when an eider
of player plays rook the c8 you always
have to be careful of rook captures and
c3 because the night is the defender of
the pawn on e4 so if the knight is
eliminated you can also grab the e4 pawn
upon and this is exactly what Maxime
does with rook captures and c3b captures
on c3 in the night captures on e4 now
this is nothing new all this has been
played before with castles and now you
don't want to waste time with Knight
captures on c3
Queen e1 you attack the night you also
prevent Queen from reaching the age
Foursquare so without wasting any time
maxime immediately was for Queen to h4
with bush of the f3 now you can always
meet Queen to g3 with just bush up to g2
it's not a problem with G captures an f5
Bishop captures an e 4f captors on e4
and now King to h2 preventing the Queen
from intro infiltrating and now there is
one game in the database from 2017
burger shop to e7 was played but not not
on such a high level here rook to g8
it's a new move it's an improvement to
Bishop to e7 and it is as a move 17 that
we have a completely new game so this is
how far along theory goes but Khurana is
prepared he's not surprised but this
move and he plays the strongest reply
rook to a for route day 4 is a is an
extremely strong move the point is that
after after white pushes for example g5
you will be able to play Queen to f3
even though your queen will be hanging
but blacks Queen will also be hanging so
this is the the the secret behind rook
to e4 and it's it can really come in
handy and black can't really start the
attacking with sounds like h5 you just
put g5 and the attack is over your
bishop nicely controls the bg5 square
you're preventing Knight to f6 and if
black wants to do anything probably
black will have to give up look for
Bishop and well and then not something
you want to do so after a bishop day for
after rook day for with Knight to f6
bringing the knight into the game and
now Fabi plays g5 just the same and this
is what we were discussing now for
example if you play Knight to h5 you get
Queen to f3 threatening Queen captures
on f7 and of course if Queen if pawn
captures then rook captures Queen
very nicely done so after g5 MVL decides
to give up yet another exchange rook
captures on g5 with Bishop Tadros on g5
Queen captures on g5 and now see for a
very important move preventing d5 you
should always prevent black from pushing
d5 in the Sicilian if you can with Queen
to h4 clearing the the g5 Square for the
bishop you want to play Bishop to h6
followed by Bishop to F
for check but Fabi of course prevents
that Queen to e1 offering a trade and
you don't really have a good square for
the Queen so here maxime trades with
Queen captures rook captures on e1 and
now comes a bishop to h6 preparing the
ship to f4 with rook to d1 threatening
the pawn here King to d7 and now c5 it's
not a problem that you've all out c5
because now white also allows d5 we've
looked to be for threatening the b7 pawn
and now King to c7 defending the pawn
and now look the b6 threatening the
night but also the bishop on h6 if the
knight moves so first bishop to f4 check
you have to play this with King to g2
and now comes Knight to d7 and now the
rook is under attack and you can't use
any of the squares on the King side
Bishop recovers this square pawn covers
this night covers f6 pawn covers this so
you could play rook here but what's the
rook really doing there you black who
just for example capture here and then
eliminate the rook or there's not all
that much to do here you can put d4 it's
not another great square for the rook so
here if a bee decides to give back some
material with rook captures on d5 Knight
captures and b6 pawn captures and v6
with check King captures and power look
to b7 now you will be able to grab some
material as a lot of those pawns are
weak with a 5 by maxime starting to push
the Queen side points rook captures on
f7 and now h6 now the bishop nicely
defends the pawns here so it's not a
problem
and yes karana is up the exchange is of
the exchange but Maxime is up two points
so it's a bit of a trade-off with King
to f2 bringing the King closer to the
action and now comes King to c6
preparing to push b5 weave into e to b5
and now Luke the f6 check with King to
c5 and now c3 preventing the King from
going deeper into the position but max
injures pushes a 4 and creates a past a
pond with beak a person a 4b captures
and now rook to a6 karana puts his rogue
behind
spawn which is what you always want to
do with King b5 attacking the rook and
rook to a7 with Bishop to g5 you want to
play again get your Bishop somewhere
well for example on this diagonal to
control a3 so you can put the pond to a3
where rook to e8 and now comes Bishop e7
as as planned with King to d2 and now a
three and now this Bishop really does a
nice job controlling controlling the
entire board with King III going after
the pond but now keep the c4 with King
captures King captures on c3 and King
captures on e5 and the now comes King to
b3 with King to e4 and now comes a 2 so
here black already has a threat for
example if white it just starts to going
after the pawns on the King side well
the pawn on the Kings side for example
king of five of course you'll see how
black wins this you just block the rook
Bishop to a three and now white is lost
after you give a couple of checks for
example King c2 you can check here check
here you're gonna go all the way here
for example check here there are no more
checks and now black just gets a queen
into the game so after a two Bobby sees
that he has to give up the rook will
look after Sammy - King captures an A -
and now comes King to f3 and here of
course
maxime is up a whole piece but he has a
dark square Bishop and the pawn Queens
I'm a light square you don't have to be
a very experienced player to know that
this is a draw but they played a few
more moves came to b3 Bobby now even
offered him a pawn so he can just
capture it but it's not a problem it's
an easily drawn endgame but maxime
decided to play a few more moves King c4
with h4 h5 King to d3 King to g2 King to
e2 and this is I mean of course they
both know this is a draw but you should
always give your opponent as as many
opportunities to make a mistake as
possible with Kings the h1 now the the
white king is is in the corner on light
square you you are unable to get away
from there as you only have a dark
square bishop so you cannot
you know attack it we've came to have to
kink to h2 and Mount Bishop to d6 Church
so here MBL gives another opportunity to
Fabi the blunder for example if King to
h3 then you lose the game after Bishop
therefore you can no longer retreat to
your precious h1 square you would have
to go up the board then King g2 King g4
you're gonna go Bishop g5 Bishop f5 and
then once you kick the King further back
you're just gonna win this pawn and get
your King over here pull th pawn and win
the game but of course Bobby did not
fall for it after Bishop b6 shirt Bobby
played King to h1 and here and we'll
just play Bishop to e5 and it was in
this position that the both players
realized it was a draw as its stalemate
the White King Kent doesn't have a
single square he can go to and the game
ended in a draw but as the court above
the board says the most exciting one was
corona versus a meal with a crazy line
of night off and I do agree definitely
the best game of the round six so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank en Hays Brandon
steinfeldt David mitts man Daniel Malak
and Gleb come check the Gleb comp check
cop chenkov for a contributor to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see soon
continuing the coverage of the sinkholes
happen maybe we were gonna have another
video today depending on how long the
games will last
continuing the capablanca saga and of
course checking up on your suggestions
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your weekend